giant turtles are among the many sea
creatures for whom coral reefs are a
vital natural habitat but that home is
changing in addition to the danger of
being caught in fishing nets turtles and
manta rays are seeing those reefs dying
out here four meters underwater just off
the island of st. Kitts the natural
world seems fine but first impressions
can be deceptive just two kilometers
away the coral reefs are in a critical
condition representatives from the
fishing authorities of six Caribbean
nations are on a diving expedition here
organised by the Nature Conservancy the
non-governmental organization has
launched a large-scale project to
investigate the condition of coral reefs
in the Caribbean with the ultimate aim
of saving them among the guests emerging
from today's dive is Christopher Elaine
from Granada it's amazing to see the
coral the fish lobster the life down
there is really good and I like to see
what I'm seeing although the general
situation around the Caribbean smaller
islands is far from good the strait
between st. Kitts and Nevis is known as
the Narrows measuring less than four
kilometers wide
this stretch of water is traversed every
day by fishing boats water taxis cruise
ships and local fairies and that leads
to conflicts the Nature Conservancy
wants to see the creation of defined
zones called marine managed areas one
would be reserved for fishermen only the
other for tourists the fishermen
traditionally they said their pots in
the Narrows but what you'll find that
because it's the the nursery ground if
it is that the the pots are there and
they're taking a juvenile fish then
those you've never fished should not get
to live to be old and to be bigger and
as scientists we know that a small fish
produces a lot less egg mil millions of
less eggs that are larger fish and so
the longer you let them grow the more
fit more eggs they can produce and the
more you get out of your fishery on some
days the fishermen's first port of call
is inland to a forest to find wood for
new fish traps they take their wood from
myrtle trees myrtle trees grow back
quickly they're accompanied by Sheree
Constantine an environmentalist who
wants to gain insights into the
fishermen's daily operations that will
in turn enabled her to decide what
changes are needed and where traps like
these have been used for decades here
the fishermen only hauled them out of
the sea once a week but due to growing
tourism they're sometimes unable to find
their tramps when water taxis or diving
boats rip their markings loose well I
think it can be very difficult
especially with you as human nature when
somebody has been doing something for a
very long time it gets harder and harder
for you to convince them that you need
to do something in a different way and
so that's one of the reasons why like a
fish a cooperative is important as well
because if you have a very good a
charismatic leader who can mobilize and
move the officials to act in a
particular way then this person can
cause change to happen in the country
we see why the changes are so critical
for the fishermen the day after they set
out to sea at five in the morning but
the hall for the day is minimal as so
often these days with stocks of
profitable fish depleted the men now
settle for smaller specimens that nobody
used to eat
it's often barely enough to make a
living and many have already quipped the
trade well it gets slow you get to
really get slow you get to Ian slow yeah
that's why we do other kind of work that
you could get a dollar st. Kitts faces a
conflict of interests the island lives
off tourism and hotel operators say the
fishermen cast their nets and traps too
close to their exclusive beaches the
practice is to be banned in the future
to allow the few corals left to survive
I want to see the fishing industry not
just continue but prosper and I firmly
believe that management of areas like
the Narrows which is a nursery and
strict management of it would be the
benefit of the fishing industry the
island and my personal business at a
workshop environmental scientists and
government guests from across the
Caribbean meet to discuss how to resolve
the conflicting interests of fishermen
and hotel managers many of the islands
already have marine managed zones
although in grenada's case it took two
years to set up the same set of
fishermen who said that we're going to
take breath away from them saying we
want more protected area so they
actually seen a different impact
unless more action is taken soon however
the korells will die out meaning even
fewer fish the hope is that the marine
managed area between st. kitts and nevis
will allow young sea creatures to
reproduce in peace again and spare
Turtles the deadly threat of being
caught in fishing nets
you